looking for Matty baners in front Jordan Everly
picks it up sends it down low to bers up to
Alexia Matty bers Rookie of the Year a season ago
a deflected Puck knocked Away by moric Jared mccan
Retreats towards the blue line down low for Everly
Jordan Everly up to will borgan the defenseman he
serves one up and a clear line of sight for
Peter marzik seeing that puck all the way in
West before the game we're going to see him again
in uh Minnesota on this road trip his daughter's
a good hockey player plays in the mini area Ellie
tolven in with the shot on goal moric the stop up
against Yanni Gord and Seattle controls the puck
Brian duml and serves one in from the point no one
knew where the puck would land Lucas reel finds
it and the three on two rush now being generated
Seth Jones there's a shot on net he picks up
the rebound brings it around up the side wall
intercepted by Yanni gourd and now Seattle Sprints
up ice gourd rattle down low alexic finds it
looking for Seth [Applause] Jones up ahead Tyler
Johnson Johnson backhanded shot on the spit Jared
mccan and the puck for Matty bener Larson a shot
tipped Away by mazic Everly the rebound Tolen in
dun tolin and a one timer off the Stick of Schwarz
to the wall bers to the puck Bard shadowed by
borgan a tough shot off the side of the net denado
looking for the rebound squirts out wide classic
over to Seth Jones in front denado score Boris
kachuk his second goal in as many games and that's
what happens when you put pucks on net first shot
to the glove side on guau and it ends up being a
good save but you see where Donado is right there
he caused a little partial screen a little bit of
a disturbance good shot by Seth Jones Seth Jones's
mentality has been to shoot the puck I talked to
him about that following the last game Phillips
has one career goal in the NHL it was against
the Kraken Dickinson to the net rebound out to
Phillips again Anderson Phillips one-time dick and
score it's two nothing Blackhawks as Jason
Dickinson's November to remember continues
that's a shot from a healthy distance right there
after Anderson puts it back to the point and he
got a lot on this one right here and a great play
by Dickinson instead of going forward he read the
the fact that this Puck may come back to him
and put himself in a good position I was right
oh I don't remember I I didn't mean to imply
that you were wrong I I just didn't remember
I wasn't I didn't have my listening ears on baners
a second shot and baners scores Maddie baners the
reigning rookie of the year but he gets Seattle
on the board well obviously Kinski thinks that
the that the forward and I believe that was Tyler
Johnson was there taking his spot I mean anytime
a defenseman's Down Low like that you need to
have a forward there kinsky saw it probably
took one glance and then he made the pass and then
there was nobody there and then the first shot was
blocked right here you see Jones puts himself
in a good position and the second one happened
so quickly that's a tough play there pinski has a
little bit of a difficult time instinctively to go
back on that entry wber wenberg still on the puck
and it drips into the net Alex wenberg scores and
the game is tied with 36 seconds to go until break
looking for the drop pass and this is this been
a bit of a difficult thing here he's looking
he's looking look at the the Seattle Kraken
they study they're they're looking at it they
they know there might be some issues or timing
sequences there and sure enough it comes back to
bite the Hawks late in the period and wall on the
power play is the play by wber kinsky thought he
was going to shoot Thomas Bryce another notable
goenda Reel with the pass to Taylor radish Tyler
Johnson scores and the Hawks get the lead right
back in the second on Tyler Johnson's sixth of
the year that's a slick wrist shot right there
really hear the noise of that puck leaving it
grow is leaning towards his left as he as he
kind of extends up here watch he's trying to
he knows it's going High glove and he pushes
up like that but it's vulnerable in that area
so so far in this game Dickinson has scored
High to the glove and same with Tyler Johnson
on that rer right there great shot Dickinson
for McKenzie an whistle an whistle voided that
hit didn't he he sure did and won the puck two
and there's a shot save grow Joey Anderson
in the slot had a great look Anderson still
on the puck wrap around score McKenzie and
whistle out a dime from Joey Anderson it's
4-2 that leads up to the goal and the forward
group on the hunt Anderson in their first and
whistle second third man high that's Dickinson
in the slot and you can see the play by Anderson
as he takes the this Puck around and on
the back hand strong against bork strand
right on the tape Dent whistle and he makes
no mistake whatsoever Jaden Schwarz maybe as
this game goes on they Haw can take advantage
of that windberg stopped by morazzi and Kyler
Yamamoto was working for a rebound opportunity
and yeah that city of Seattle they got to be
pretty pumped up about the Winter Classic
coming their way Ellie Tolen in centering
feed traffic in front p got in the crease
Hawk sweep it away Alexia thrown in front
Everly to the crashing cier backhand alexc save
mazic Everly and a bigger save by [Applause]
mazic big stuff from morzak [Music]
net radish on the feet from Pinsky Nick Felino and
hit Jason Dickinson up high after AUM Dickinson
radish for Felino in [Applause] front Schultz in
front knocked away Belmar off the Stick of Bard
ah good stick there Hawks have a rush Brewing
Bard cuts for kurashev and group hour the save
Nick Felino grabbs it Felino Kev driving the net
and it's broken up by bers wow great skating by
bers 200 ft of play on display for bers now
Kier scores for Seattle and it's all Maddie
baners at the controls it absolutely is that's
exactly what K was saying to him I mean what
a play bers last year's called her Trophy winner
baring down the right side this is after he broke
up the play in the defensive zone so it results
on the offensive side but the reason it happened
is what he did coming back in his own Zone
poking the puck away from what looked like
a beautiful pass from the forward Felino
who went to his backand Jason Dickinson
flicks across save through bow open net Isaac
Phillips had the shot Schultz wenberg back to
Schultz here Potter rolski tolin in a
big stop by morazzi mazic again Here's
the the the fake shot for tolvanen on a little
redirection a need to hold on for seven more
seconds three
seconds and the Hawks and the
playoff team from last season a
4-3 defeat they finish the home stand two and one